SPEAKER 1: Sweet.
All right, well thank
you all for joining.
I'm happy here to
have Celeste Headlee.
Celeste has been a
journalist since 1999.
She's worked as reporter,
producer, and host
in Public Radio on
the local, national,
and international level.
She started her
broadcasting career
at Arizona Public
Radio in Flagstaff,
then moved to WDET in Detroit
before taking a job with NPR.
She's also a TED speaker.
And she wrote this excellent
book called "We Need to Talk."
It's really awesome.
And she's going to share
some tips on conversation,
and what we could do to
become better in conversation.
So without much further
ado, let's welcome Celeste.
[APPLAUSE]
CELESTE HEADLEE: Most of
us have a pretty hard time
accepting that we're not
great conversationalists.
Generally, we seem
to think, when
we have a conversation that goes
bad, we blame the other person.
And in fact, that's
not just my opinion.
There's a lot of
really good research
that shows that we actually rate
our conversational skills much
higher than they actually
are, just in general.
And there's two
things going on there.
The first is the smarter
you are, the harder it
is for you to be
good in conversation.
Being smart in general is
actually pretty helpful.
Logic has probably
helped you solve
a lot of problems in your life.
But they don't help
you when you're
talking to another human being.
And that's because human
beings, even you, are inherently
emotional and illogical.
Reason is not,
our logical skills
are not why we have
succeeded on the planet.
It wasn't our logic
and our reason.
Actually it was our soft
skills and our hive mind.
So emotion isn't
actually a weakness,
even though we think
of it that way.
And we try to punish other
people when they bring emotion
to a conversation, right.
So the problem is, is that you
can't just rely on your IQ.
An EQ is almost more
important in a conversation
than an IQ is.
You can't even
trust your own logic
when you're in a conversation.
You can't even
trust your own logic
when you're solving
a logical problem,
let alone an emotional problem.
And I say that because, if
you look at the work of say,
Nobel Prize-winning
psychologist Daniel Kahneman.
And he was the one that
said that, very often, we
rely on system 1 thinking.
So what is system 1 thinking?
It's really, really useful.
So you're getting
out of the subway,
and you see a really disheveled,
dirty, kind of smelly guy.
And he's sitting on a piece
of cardboard on the ground.
And you say, that's a
homeless guy, right.
That's system 1 thinking.
You're making an
assumption about that.
And we do it all the time.
And it helps us,
because if we actually
had to reason through
every single thing
that we encountered
in daily life,
we would get we would get stuck.
We'd never get through anything.
The problem is, is that
system 1 thinking is really
easily deluded.
And we make assumptions all the
time in conversations, right.
We assume we know what
someone's about to say,
so we interrupt them.
We assume we know
what they mean,
so then we come up
with our response
before they've even
finished their sentence.
So system 1 thinking
is not always wrong,
it's just often wrong.
And one of the ways that
Kahneman-- who I again
want to emphasize is
a psychologist, not
a mathematician --one of the
ways he demonstrated this
was by presenting these
really simple math
problems to students at MIT
and Princeton and Harvard.
So, for example, he would say,
a baseball and a bat together
cost $1.10.
The bat costs a dollar
more than the ball does.
How much does the ball cost?
And most of the students
said the ball costs $0.10.
But the bat costs a
dollar more than the ball
does, which means the
ball is actually $0.05,
and the baseball bat is $1.05.
And it's the same thing, he had
another problem where he said,
what was it, there's a
patch of lily pads on a lake
and every day the
patch doubles in size.
It takes 48 days
for the lily pads
to completely cover the lake.
How long does it
take for the lily
pads to cover half the lake?
Well most people just
divide it in half, right.
And they say 24.
But it takes 47 days.
Because if it doubles in
size, then the day before it
covered the whole lake,
it covered half the lake.
See, system 1
thinking is even going
to steer you wrong when you're
dealing with math problems.
So you can imagine how
much it gets screwed up
when you're dealing
with me, who's
full of emotion, and memory,
and illogical decisions.
There's another little
wrinkle to this.
And you may have heard
a little bit about this,
but I'll tell you the story
of Justin Kruger and David
Dunning, knowing perfectly
well you probably Googled this
before.
But back in 1999,
they were trying
to figure out how
to train people,
how to train them
more efficiently.
So they tested hundreds, if
not thousands, of people.
And what they did was
they gave them tests.
And after they'd
taken the test, they
would say, OK, rate how well
you think you did on the test.
How many problems do
you think you got wrong?
And then rate how
well you think you did
in comparison to other people.
Right?
And what they discovered
was, the more ignorant
you are on a subject,
the more likely
you are to think that
you're above average.
The exact same
competence that's needed
to have knowledge
of a subject is
what is needed to actually
evaluate competence.
If you're incompetent
in physics,
you don't know if a physics
problem is hard or easy.
If you're a novice
in tennis, you
don't know if a play that
Serena Williams just executed
is difficult or not, right.
If you know nothing about
wine, you'll taste the wine
and be like, this is delicious.
But you actually
don't have any idea.
And it goes the other way also,
except there's a wrinkle when
you are competent.
The people who did
really well on the test
consistently underestimated
how well they did.
And it wasn't that they didn't
know what they got wrong or got
right.
They were actually
pretty accurate
in knowing what they got
wrong or what they got right.
Where it went wonky was when
they compared themselves
to other people, because they
assumed everyone was competent.
So they, in comparison
with others,
underrated themselves thinking
that everyone basically shared
the base level of competence.
OK, so why am I
telling you this?
It's because 99
times out of 100,
when people ask me
about conversation,
it's about how to change
someone else's behavior.
It's about how to stop somebody
else from interrupting you.
Or how to stop somebody from
running on and on and on
and boring you to death.
Or how to get out of a
conversation you don't
want to be in, blah blah blah.
And there's good news
and the bad news on this.
And the bad news is you can't.
You cannot change
someone else's behavior.
The good news is, you
can change your own.
And there's probably
room for improvement.
The other step of
good news there
is that modeling
behavior is really
strong among human beings.
If you model good
conversational etiquette,
it's really likely that
the people that you talk to
on a regular basis
will eventually
begin to imitate the kind
of conversational habits
that you have.
So this comes up all
the time at work,
right, because we tend to
think of our soft skills,
the soft skills we hate talking
about, as a waste of time.
We see them as a
distraction, or they're
getting in the way
of what we want to do
and our coworker keeps talking
about her kids dance recital,
blah blah blah blah blah.
But in fact, your
conversations are a way
to make your work better.
They can make you
better at what you do,
both at work and at home.
You know, one of
the most powerful
psychological and sociological
tools that we have now
is the MRI, the FMRI.
Being able to scan a brain
and watch it thinking
while that person
is still conscious
has made us aware of
all kinds of things
that we didn't, I
guess didn't accept,
or weren't aware of before.
So there's this
great research that
came out of Harvard in 2014.
And what they discovered is
that talking about yourself
activates the exact
same pleasure center
in the brain as sex and heroin.
It's inherently pleasurable,
and not by a small amount.
So I want you to think for
just a moment about maybe
the last time you
had a job interview
and you thought it went great.
And then you didn't get called.
Or maybe a date,
you went on a date,
and you're like,
we totally clicked.
That was fantastic.
But you never got
called back then.
That's because your experience
of that conversation
might have been very
different from theirs.
It screws with our
perception all the time.
Now at this point,
it becomes a problem
because one of the ways we have
of fixing this communication
problem is through
face-to-face and voice-to-voice
conversation.
Human beings are evolutionarily,
biologically, cosmo--
I mean, just universally
designed beautifully
to communicate face-to-face.
Or even through the voice,
to detect nuances and changes
in your voice, to detect body
language and know what it is.
You can walk into a room,
right, and without anyone saying
anything you know if you're
either at a funeral or a party.
We don't give that
very much credence,
but that's actually--
that's huge.
That's an incredible skill
that human beings have
that many other
creatures don't have.
The problem is when you remove
any kind of human interaction,
either between looking
at somebody's face
or hearing their voice, right.
How many of you would
rather send an email
than make a phone call?
And be honest, because
I know the statistics.
Raise your hand if you'd
rather send an email.
OK.
It's gotten so
bad at this point,
that there's big
companies like Coke
and JP Morgan Chase that
have pretty much eliminated
their voicemail systems.
They don't even have
it available anymore.
So in the year 2000, Americans
sent 14 billion texts
per month.
In 2000.
By 2010, 10 years later,
it was 188 billion.
And four years after
that, it was 561 billion.
We spend almost a half
an hour every day,
the average American adult,
texting, and only six minutes
on the phone.
We don't actually know at this
point what effect that growth
has on our brains.
The research lags so
far behind, because it
takes so long to do
a clinical study,
that we don't at
this point know what
effect the intrusion of
social media and smartphones
has on our human
relationships and our brains.
But I can tell you
one thing, empathy
has declined by insane amounts.
The University of
Michigan did a survey
that compiled the results of
about 72 different studies.
And what they found is that
over a course of 30 years,
empathy declined by 40%.
And almost all of that happened
between, say 2000 and 2011.
So I get it.
Correlation is not causation.
But it's kind of hard to
not see a relationship
between the rise in all
of this communication,
digital communication,
and the reduction
in our own human empathy
and relationships
between each other.
So I wanted to stay with
empathy for just a moment,
because empathy is not one
of those dreaded soft skills
that we talk about.
Empathy has a real purpose,
and it's important.
It has an evolutionary purpose.
It has a sociological purpose
and a societal purpose.
And the loss of empathy
is really troubling.
It can cause us
some real problems.
And if you're looking
around at the world,
not just in the US
where it's bad enough,
but at Brexit, and
the migrant crisis,
and all those things going
on in other places as well,
you can see we need
empathy in order
to be able to get
along with one another.
The difference between
empathy and sympathy
is, sympathy is when
you say to somebody,
you know, I feel bad for you.
I feel for you.
I'm sorry that happened to you.
Empathy is when you
say, I feel with you.
I can understand
what that's like.
I can imagine what I
would feel like if I
were in that same situation.
And it's a really, really
crucial survival skill.
So again, I'm at Google.
I'm not talking about
putting away your tech.
I am not anti-tech.
I wear a Fitbit.
I've got a Surface tablet.
I have pretty much every
possible technology
I could possibly get.
My entire radio
show is basically
operated from Google Drive.
Like, I am not anti-tech.
But there are things that
tech does really, really well.
There are things that tech
does better than human beings.
And there are things that human
beings do better than tech,
and will always do
better than tech.
And we need to learn
to separate those two.
We need to start being honest
about what is an inherently
human skill, and what is an
inherently technological skill,
and then render unto
Caesar what is Caesar's.
So that's kind of what we're
going to be talking about.
And the biggest
barrier to conversation
is that phone that all
of you probably have,
if not in your hands,
then close enough.
Let me tell you
about this study.
The average adult,
by this point,
checks-- and this
was, this is research
that is a few years old, so
it's probably more than this,
but the average adult checks
their phone about 110 times
a day.
And that's about once
every 13 seconds.
It peaks at about once every
six seconds in the evenings,
by the way.
And the problem with
that is that the phone
is having effects on your
brain that you're not actually
aware of.
So they did these
studies in Britain
in which they brought in a
whole bunch of people strangers.
They had never met each other.
And they just had them have
five to 10 minute conversations.
In half of those
conversations, they went in
and they just placed a
cell phone on the table.
It didn't belong to
either of the people.
It did not make any noise.
They just set it
there on the table.
And in those situations in which
there was a cell phone sitting
on the table, the
pairs of people
were something like
60% to 70% more
likely to say the other person
was unfriendly, untrustworthy,
unempathetic, and unlikable.
So I want you to think about
how many times you've sat down
to have lunch with a
friend or something,
and you just set your
phone on the table,
but you felt really
good about it
because you didn't look at it.
What you don't realize is that,
subconsciously, your brain
is aware of that phone.
It's having an effect
on the other person.
It's also having
an effect on you.
Because there's really great
research on distraction.
And what that those
studies show us,
is that even when your
phone makes no noise at all,
your brain is aware of it.
And it's actually in
fight or flight mode,
prepared to respond
should it make noise.
Part of your brain power is
occupied in paying attention
to the email client
that you have
open in the background of
your computer at all times.
It's distracting you.
You're just not aware of it.
So a lot of us get
advice on conversation.
And almost all of it is crap.
We have heard, you
know, nod your head
to show that you're listening.
Say uh-huh, maintain eye
contact at all times.
Believe me, I've
tried it all out.
It is terrible advice.
You know, instead
of learning how
to pretend that you're paying
attention, which is basically
what nodding and
saying uh-huh is,
it's way more authentic when
you actually pay attention.
So I want you to actually
forget the advice
you've had on small talk.
There's no phrases
that you can use.
There's nothing that you need to
avoid saying, except for things
like "I'm not a racist, but."
Avoid that.
Other than that,
there's no catch phrases
to either use or not use
that are going to help you.
Because it's all
about you being who
you are as an individual,
and recognizing
that other person being who
they are as an individual.
And that's always
going to be different.
So I want to start
with the 10 things
that you can actually do to
make your conversations better.
And I would recommend that
you choose one, choose
one thing that you can do.
Don't leave the
room and be like,
I'm going to be the best
conversationalist ever.
No, that's not going to happen.
But choose one, and
choose the easiest,
the one that you think
you can make that change
without a lot of effort.
So the first one
is don't multitask.
And you've probably already
seen a lot of the research.
Human beings can't multitask.
It's not possible for
our brains to focus
on one thing at the
same time that we're
doing something else.
But some of the other research
shows, there's a few things.
A, the attempt to
multitask, when
you're trying to
do multiple things,
it pumps dopamine
into your brain.
It feels really, really good.
But the other side of dopamine,
you probably already know,
is that you then crash.
So if you have spent the
day trying to multitask,
you're going to go home at the
end of the day more exhausted
and feeling more
fatigued than if you'd
done one thing at a time.
That's the first thing.
The second thing
is that the quality
of your work of both tasks,
say you're on a conference call
but you're also answering email,
quality of work for both things
goes down by about 20%.
And your IQ drops by 10 points.
So I wouldn't do that.
And certainly not
in conversation.
And I don't mean just
putting your phone down.
What I mean is being present
in that moment, being
there in that conversation.
Not trying to listen to somebody
while you're thinking about a
fight that you just had.
And that's not always possible.
It's not always
possible to be present.
And so therefore, if
you can't be present
and it's not an
urgent conversation,
it's better to walk away.
If you're not able to
focus and pay attention,
it's better to put
that conversation off
until there's a time
when you can actually
be there for the conversation.
Because otherwise,
you're basically
wasting both of your time.
The second thing is
don't pontificate.
Now pontificate
means to lecture.
What I'm doing right
now is pontificating.
But we're not in a conversation.
And this is another
particularly difficult thing
for smart people
because we know a lot.
And so people will start
talking about something,
and we'll start telling
everybody everything
that we know about that subject.
That's not a good conversation.
You should not go
into a conversation
trying to educate other people.
Just believe me.
My book goes into exactly
all the reasons why.
But it's going to turn
that other person off.
And they won't
listen to you anyway.
They will absorb almost nothing
of what you say to them.
So don't waste your time, right.
Instead, just have
a conversation,
and enter into the
conversation assuming that you
have something to learn.
It's best to just
give up on going
into a conversation trying
to change anybody's mind
or trying to educate anybody.
This point is going to
come up a little bit later.
But you basically have
to be quiet and just
let people speak.
I'm not actually
worried that you
have had people who said,
well, if I do what you say,
I will never get to talk.
I'm not actually
worried about that.
There's very few
people in this world
that I'm concerned about
that would just stop talking.
That's not a concern.
But you're probably not
listening as much as
that you think that you are.
But also you're just missing
out on a lot of things
other people have to tell you.
Just because someone is
not educated, or maybe even
not smart, doesn't mean they're
not an expert in something.
I mean this is how
Bill Nye says it.
But what I always say,
and one of the things that
has been most surprising to
me over my career in NPR is,
everybody is an
expert in something.
Everybody.
There's something that high
school dropout truck driver
knows better than anybody else.
His area or her
area of expertise.
And if you go around with
an effort to find that,
find what it is that makes
someone else really an expert,
you're going to be one of the
smartest people on the planet.
I mean, even Larry
King says, you know,
I'm not going to learn
anything from what I say today.
The only way I'm going
to learn is by listening.
And if all you're
doing is walking
around telling people what
you know, you're not growing.
You are learning nothing.
So view everybody as a
receptacle of information
which is 100% unique to them.
Some of it is probably crap.
Some of it is wrong.
But, you know what?
That's true of you,
too, statistically.
That's also true.
So you can get through
that, and you can find
real nuggets of information.
Not always, but a lot of times.
The third one is
open-ended questions.
And this is something that
journalists use all the time
to get better information
and better interviews out
of people.
That means a question that
starts with who, what, where,
when, why or how.
And the formula for
a young reporter
is that, if you put a
complicated question in,
you will get a
simple answer out.
And if you put a
simple answer in,
you'll get a
complicated answer out.
In other words, we
often ask questions
in which we're trying to
steer their response, right.
And you hear this from bad
interviewers all the time.
You know, you were
in a hurricane
and the winds were going blah
blah blah 120 miles an hour.
And I guess you haven't
even found your dog yet,
and your roof just peeled off.
Oh my god, that must
have been terrifying.
The better thing is, the
hurricane hit your house.
You were still here.
What happened?
How did you feel?
What did you hear?
What happened to your dog?
Why can't you find your dog?
Let them take
control at that point
and tell you what happened.
Let them have that moment.
Because they were the one that
was actually experiencing it.
And this is really, really
important with coworkers,
especially if you're a manager.
You need to let the other
person actually describe what
it is they're going through.
And try to resist the temptation
to assume you know what they're
about to say, and interrupt
them and then describe
what it is that you think
that they're saying.
That's what leads to
really bad communication.
There was actually, I was at the
TED summit last year in Banff.
And this nuclear scientist
from Japan comes up to me,
and he says, you know I watched
your TED talk like three times
and I still can't figure out
how to start a conversation.
And I said, well, where
are you from in Japan?
And he says, I'm from Kyoto.
And I said, you know I've
never actually been there.
Is that like Tokyo?
Is it like all packed,
really crowded?
And he goes, no no no no.
It's more spread out.
You've seen the pictures
of all the temples
and the cherry blossoms.
And I was like oh, so do most
people have an apartment?
Or they have a house
with an actual yard?
And so he starts describing it,
and about 5 or 10 minutes later
I said, that's how you
start a conversation.
You ask questions that they know
the answer to about something
they care about.
That's it.
And that's why small
talk is so easy.
And it's so rewarding
for your brain.
And your life
expectancy gets longer
if you actually talk to
your neighbors and strangers
on the subway.
You actually, your blood
pressure goes down.
Small talk that everyone
thinks is not worth your time
and you'd rather
stare at your phone,
small talk is
really good for you.
Really good for you, even if
it's about nothing important,
like the weather or the most
recent raise in gas prices.
Even those totally meaningless
conversations are great for you
as a human being.
And they have zero
investment, right.
You're not happy with it?
You say excuse me, and you go
back to your cell phone, right.
They say something offensive?
You say hmm, it's been
nice talking to you,
and you go back to
your cell phone.
Zero risk.
No commitment.
I highly recommend that
you just start talking
to everybody that you can.
Your Uber driver,
whoever it is, just
have these meaningless
conversations.
Believe me, if you're not
happier a month or two later,
you can email me and complain.
Full money back guarantee.
OK.
The fourth one is
go with the flow.
So, going with the flow
means actually allowing
the conversation
to evolve, and not
inserting your own thoughts.
So let's say someone says, well
let's meet at Starbucks later.
And suddenly you remember that
time you were at Starbucks
and you saw Ellen DeGeneres,
and she admired your shirt
or whatever.
And so you stop listening
to everything else
they just said, and you're
just waiting for them
to take a breath so you can
tell your story about Ellen
Degeneres.
That's what I want
you to stop doing.
You can't stop the thoughts
from coming into your head.
They're going to,
but what you can do
is let go of those
thoughts and let
them flow right out of
your head and go back
to what it was the
other person was saying.
Part of this occurs through
mindfulness training,
but it's just about not
holding on to those ideas that
come into your
head and turning it
into a self-promotional video.
Besides, you probably told Ellen
Degeneres story too many times.
OK, number five
is another big one
that smart people
have a problem with.
And if you don't know, just
say that you don't know.
I bet you can probably guess
the profession, the number one
profession that has the
hardest time with this one.
What profession do you think
would have the hardest time
saying I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Priests.
CELESTE HEADLEE:
It's a good guess,
but actually it's surgeons.
Surgeons can't seem to bring
themselves to say I don't know.
And this has become a problem,
right, because they guess.
So there have been studies
done based in medical offices.
And one of them in which they
had their control group just
continue on as they were
doing, and this was with GPs,
this one wasn't
even with surgeons.
And the other one they
said, every time you don't
know an answer just say, I don't
know but I'm going to find out.
That's it, they just replaced
their guesses with that phrase.
And at the end of the
study, the patients who
had the second group liked
their doctors better,
their estimation of
their intelligence
went up significantly,
their belief
in their credibility
and their knowledge
went up significantly.
And I realize it seems
counter-intuitive
that saying I don't know makes
people think you know more.
But when you try to figure that
out, it actually makes sense.
Because the fact of the matter
is is we can't know everything.
And so when you pretend
to know everything,
people know that
some of it is BS.
They just don't know which
is BS and which isn't.
So they're going
to view everything
you say with a grain of salt.
And when I say you
don't know, reading
the first couple of
paragraphs or the preview
that shows up in your
Google search on a subject
is not the same as knowing.
You need to actually be
an expert on a subject
before you offer any
unsolicited advice.
Actually forget that, don't
offer unsolicited advice.
But don't say you
know something,
don't say a movie's
great or terrible,
unless you've seen the movie.
Don't base it off
somebody else's review.
Just say I don't know.
The sixth one is don't equate
your experience with other
people's.
And this one is
surprisingly, to me at least,
the hardest one for
people to accept.
So if somebody says,
I just lost my job,
do not tell them
about the time you
lost your job two years ago.
Or if someone's dog died, do
not tell them about the time
that you lost your dog.
And I know this is
difficult for people
because we think that what
we're doing is empathetic.
And I say that because
that's been my intention when
I've done that, and
I've done it plenty.
And in the book I share a
particularly still-painful--
like my cheeks
still got hot when
I think about that --moment,
because it was so bad.
You think that what
you're saying to them is,
I've been through this.
It's going to be OK.
But you haven't been through it.
You haven't.
You've been through something
that's kind of similar.
But you're a different
person in a different place
with different resources.
And even just as
importantly, human beings,
when they're comfortable,
your accuracy,
your empathetic accuracy,
goes into the toilet.
So if you lost your job two
years ago but now you're OK,
you are more likely to
underestimate how much
the other person is suffering.
If you went through a
divorce three years ago,
and now it's three years later
and someone just found out
they're going to
get a divorce, you
are more likely
to think it's not
that bad, because our comfort
makes us incapable of actually
analyzing or estimating the
other person's feelings.
And so you're more likely to
say things which are not good
to say, like, it's going to
be OK or, it's all right,
everything happens for
a reason or, who knows,
this could be the
universe closing the door
and opening a window.
Those are terrible
things to say.
They're not good.
And the number one worst
thing that you could say
is, I know how you feel,
because you do not.
You don't.
It's just like the
open-ended questions.
You need to ask them.
If they have come to you
with a struggle or a pain,
it means what they
need right now
is to be able to describe
what they're going through.
That's what they're there for.
They're not there to hear
about your experience
that you had a
couple of years ago.
I know this is hard
to let go, too.
I totally get it.
But believe me, you're
never going to say, gee,
I really regret
telling about myself
in that particular moment.
Like, that's never going to be
a mistake, unless they ask you,
you went through a
divorce three years ago.
What lawyer did you use?
How did that go for you?
Then, all bets are off,
out of the gates, go ahead.
Otherwise, let them talk.
Number seven is don't
repeat yourself.
So it's not only women.
Everybody does this,
but women especially
tend to repeat themselves.
And part of the reason is
we'll give instructions
to someone, a kid or a
husband or spouse or partner,
and we don't get
the acknowledgment
of what we just said.
And so we go about rephrasing
it a bunch of times.
Now, the other class of
person that does this a lot
is managers.
Like you'll be in a
meeting, and they'll say OK,
so the deadline is 4:00 PM.
And then they'll go on talking
and they'll say, now remember,
if it doesn't get
to us by 4:00 PM,
such and such terrible, dire
thing is going to happen.
And then later on they
rephrase it, and rephrase it,
and rephrase it.
Now, not only is
that really boring.
But more importantly, right,
because everything you
say is really important, right.
More importantly,
you're training them
not to listen to you.
And this is especially true
with children, but also spouses.
They're not going to pay
attention to you because they
know you're going to repeat it.
That's what you're
training them to do.
I'm going to say this again.
So I would highly recommend
that, especially if it's
important information,
you get people into the--
do you think Colin Powell
repeats himself when
he tells people to do things?
He does not.
He says it once, and then you're
culpable if it doesn't happen.
And you deserve the same
respect as Colin Powell.
So just say it once.
Don't bore people, and
don't train them not
to listen to you.
Just don't say it again.
The first few times
that happens with a kid,
I can tell you from
experience, it's painful.
But, especially if you make
the stakes high like I did,
like I'm taking your
car in to the shop.
You're not going to
have it for three days.
And then he gets ready to
go to work the next day
and he's like, where's my car?
And I'm like, I told you.
I'm doing this thing where
I only tell you once.
Yeah, it can be painful,
but it absolutely works.
OK, number eight is
stay out of the weeds.
And by the weeds, when
journalists say the weeds,
they mean unnecessary
details, things
that people don't need to know.
Now this happens a lot
with doctors and scientists
and computer programmers
and software engineers,
that they just tell you details
that are totally unnecessary.
But it happens in your
regular conversations
all the time, too.
Someone will say, well, I'm
going to Italy next year.
And you'll say, oh my
god Italy is so great.
I went there in 2011.
No, you know what?
It was 2012, because
Julie had just graduated.
You know what?
It wasn't.
it was, it had to
have been 2013,
because we'd just bought that
Volvo because the other one
had--
I mean, at that
point they are gone,
and you will probably
not get them back.
That's it.
Nobody cares about that stuff.
Now, keeping track
of those things
is actually quite good
for your own brain,
so I highly recommend
a journal or blog.
But don't journal or blog
all over other people.
Just keep the details out of it.
Now this next one is
the most important one.
So this is the one we're going
to spend the most time on,
and it's listening.
Now, I said that
research shows us
that we tend to overestimate
our skills at conversation,
and that's especially
true of listening.
But it's not really
our fault. Human beings
are just not designed
to listen well.
And even going
back decades, back
to the father of
listening, Ralph Nichols,
they showed that if they
made people listen to someone
talking for like 10 minutes,
and they would tell them
we're going to test you
on this when it's done,
so listen carefully.
Immediately after that
person stopped talking,
people only retained
50% of what they heard.
48 hours later, it
was down to 25%,
and three months
later it was all gone.
We do not retain
information well.
That's why Google's so
successful as a search engine,
right.
We need something else to
retain information and make
it archivable.
We don't do that, which means
it requires training and effort
and energy for us to actually
listen in an engaged way.
If you're not doing
that, though, you're
not actually having
conversations.
So, I mean Buddha said,
if my mouth is open,
I'm not learning, right.
I mean there are so many
incredibly smart people who've
talked about just the
crucialness of listening
as a skill.
I mean I could spend the rest
of the time just quoting them.
But business people
and academics
have said it's one of
the top three or five,
depending on which
one you look at,
most important skills you
need for success in business.
But in fact, if you look
at business journals,
1.5% of the articles
deal with listening.
How many of you, at some point,
were offered a public speaking
course?
Most of you.
How many of you were
offered a listening course?
Right.
So the thing of it is,
is that we actually have
to be trained in how to listen.
There's this great research
coming out of Australia and New
Zealand in their
school system there
in which what they
discovered is that, in order
to improve your
listening skills,
you can't learn it
through osmosis.
You don't learn to listen
during history class.
You only learn to listen
when somebody tells you now
we're going to learn
how to listen better,
and then you actually
get training specifically
in listening.
And if anyone's
had an infant, you
know we're not born
knowing how to listen.
We're born knowing
how to scream.
We talk really well.
We don't listen very well.
And the reason I say this
is because you're not
going to leave this
room and say like,
oh, I'm going to be a
great listener from now on.
You are not.
It's going to take
discipline and practice,
and sometimes you're not going
to have the energy for it,
and that's OK.
It's OK to walk
away at that point.
I am not about
more conversation.
I'm about better conversations
when you have them.
So, I mean, one of the
reasons that we don't listen
is because we get distracted.
And one of the reasons
we get distracted
is because the
average person talks
at about 150 words per minute.
I'm from LA.
I talk considerably
faster than that.
But you listen at up to
450 words per minute.
So there's an extra
300 words in there
that our brains are filling in.
And we are inherently
interesting to ourselves.
So, what we're thinking is
sometimes more interesting
that what the other
person is saying.
That's why letting stuff go out
of your brain is so important.
Because you have to be
able to let those 300 words
go by and still return to what
that other person is saying.
As Stephen Covey
said, most of us
don't listen with the
intent to understand,
we listen with the
intent to reply.
And almost all of us
do that, worldwide.
Worldwide, the amount of time
between one person ending
a sentence and the
other person responding,
is less than half a
second, worldwide,
which means nobody
is actually listening
to everything
somebody has to say
before they think about what
it is they need to say next.
And I highly recommend
you get in the habit
of taking a breath.
Up that average.
Take a breath to absorb
what someone else has said,
and really think about
it, before you respond.
OK the last one,
number 10, is be brief.
So you probably already know
that our attention spans
are shrinking.
Microsoft has done incredible
work on our attention spans.
I don't know who the
poor researcher was
that had to watch the fish
all day, but at this point
our attention spans,
especially on the internet,
is eight seconds at a time
before we're distracted,
and that's one second less
than that of a goldfish.
We get distracted really easily.
I'm not saying
that's a bad thing.
It may not be.
Who knows, maybe
evolutionarily there's
a real advantage to that.
But I will say that if you talk
for several minutes at a time
without allowing the
other person to respond,
you're going to lose them.
That's just the
fact of the matter.
I try to use a game
of catch as an example
of a good, healthy conversation.
Because in a game of catch, if
it's friendly and you're both
trying to have fun, you cannot
throw more times than you
catch.
It's an even split
between the two.
Not only that, you
don't hold onto the ball
for minutes at a time.
You throw it back immediately.
And you throw it in
a way where you're
trying to let them catch it.
If it's a fun
game, right, you're
not pegging it off 500 yards.
Yeah, well, 500
yards, nice throw,
but you're not pegging
it off the other way
so they can't catch it.
You're setting each
other up for success.
And you're sharing the space.
I gave a speech to ESPN,
and now one of their CEOs
keeps a ball on his
desk at all times,
just to remind him to let
the other person talk.
And I would say the same to you.
The last thing I want to talk
to you about is neural coupling.
And this is also pretty recent
research out of Princeton.
So what they discovered,
this gets me all geeked out,
so what they discovered is
that when one person is telling
a personal story,
like in this case
they used a girl telling a
story about a disastrous prom
she had, and then they
hooked them all up to FMRIs
and they let other people
listen to her story.
What they found was that
when people were listening
in an engaged way, their brains'
waves synced up almost exactly.
In fact so exactly that,
at times, the listener
would anticipate changes
in the speaker's brain
by a fraction of a second.
Like they call it neural
coupling, but it's mind meld,
right.
That's mind meld.
It's amazing, right.
If Gene Roddenberry
had written it
in Star Trek we'd be like, well,
that's never going to happen.
It's totally real.
And this is what we
give up when we text.
This is what you give up
when you use an emoji.
This is inherently human.
We are able to
connect on a level
that no emoji or
digital device is ever
going to be able to replicate.
So keep your technology.
Use your technology for
all the things it does well
but reclaim this.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: My first question is
when did you have the epiphany
to start writing this book?
CELESTE HEADLEE: So that's
really, you've read the book,
so you already read-- that's
where the book starts,
is that I was doing research
for a story on flight safety.
And I read, part
of my research, I
read the transcript of the black
box recording of a plane that
went down outside of
D.C. And it was snowy,
the pilot hadn't had a lot of
experience with cold weather,
he chose to take off before
de-icing the plane engine one
more time, and they
crashed within minutes
and just about everybody died,
only two people survived.
But when you read the
black box recording,
the co-pilot repeatedly tries
to say something's wrong,
keeps tapping the
instruments saying, you know,
that doesn't look right.
Buh buh buh buh bah, and the
pilot says no, it's all fine.
And there was a lot of
different developments
that came out of that
particular crash.
We learned a lot from it.
But one of the things that
the FAA investigators thought
was, well we need
to teach co-pilots
how to be more assertive.
And my thought was, why
can't we teach pilots
how to listen better?
You know, I mean
granted, most of us
aren't going to have
a conversation where
there's lives in the balance.
But frankly, in hospitals,
thousands of people
die every year because of
miscommunications in hospitals.
That's just the truth.
And that's, those
numbers are small,
because the only ones
we're able to track
are the ones in which there
was a malpractice suit filed.
So it's more than that.
I mean, there are lives
at stake over the fact
that we can't communicate.
And in the business
world, I'm not
trying to compare
human life to money,
but we lose trillions of dollars
every year to miscommunication,
a lot of it caused
by email, frankly.
Email is the devil when
it comes to communication.
There's only-- there's very few
things that email does better
than a phone call, very few.
But that was sort of
the epiphany for me,
was like, we're looking at
communication all wrong.
It's not about the talker,
it's about the listener.
SPEAKER 1: Why do
you think we focus
so much time on becoming
better communicators,
and not listeners?
CELESTE HEADLEE:
Well, right, because
like the cult of personality.
I mean, when people are
talking about Steve Jobs,
they're talking about the guy
standing in front of the screen
and being so inspiring.
And TED talks, you
know, somebody up
there blowing your
mind because they're
such an incredible speaker.
And we've also gotten to
this place in social media
where everyone's getting
these personal brands,
and everyone has a blog.
And you could argue
that Faceblog is sort--
Facebook is kind of a
living blog for everybody
at all times.
Like, it's always about
creating your own identity.
And we're trying to do
it in a vacuum, right.
We want to create our own
identity without anybody
getting in our way.
And so we also want
to stay in control,
like we don't want to hear
things that we don't like.
We don't want to talk about
stuff that we don't like.
We want to customize
the human experience.
We want to be able to
unfriend people, like,
as they're talking to us.
Unfriend, go away.
You know, we have
created this reality
in which we think we can avoid
inconvenience and things that
bother us.
But the truth of it is, is
that that mess and that chaos
is actually, that's
the good stuff.
I mean that's the good stuff.
You're going to have to
sift through some crap.
But in the end,
the true epiphanies
and inspiration and
imagination, that's
going to come through that
chaos, not outside of it.
SPEAKER 1: So kind of like going
through the suffering process,
surviving it, enduring it.
CELESTE HEADLEE: The
crucible of your character.
SPEAKER 1: Now does that
connect to your other point
about how you said
younger generations are
showing an empathy gap?
CELESTE HEADLEE: Yeah.
Well, you know,
digital communication
allows us to be the
worst possible iteration
of ourselves.
They've done a lot of
stories on our personalities
in email, for example, and we
tend to be less cooperative,
we're more insulting,
we're ruder,
and we're less likely
to negotiate in email.
And there's other things too.
For example, an apology
that's written down
has no effect on the brain.
Like in order for you to
reach closure and forgiveness
after a slight has
occurred, there's
a biological and
neurological process
that has to process
that has to happen,
and the first step of that is
the compassion center, right.
That the person has to
have compassion for you
before they can begin
all that other stuff.
So if you text someone, or
even email them, I'm sorry,
nothing happens.
It absolutely never touches
the compassion center,
which means that entire process
of forgiveness and letting
go never even begins.
The thing of it is,
the reason why we email
and text instead of calling is
because it's hard to apologize.
It's difficult. And we'd
rather avoid it if we could.
But the fact of
the matter is, is
it's the struggle that actually
makes the apology worth it.
So the other person either hears
us struggling to apologize,
or they see us struggling,
and suddenly bing,
the compassion center lights up.
And that begins
that whole thing.
So it's basically useless
to apologize over email.
It's a complete waste of time.
The other person
may smile at you
and pretend like they let
it go, but the chances are,
it's going to stay
there forever and ever.
You'll never reach closure.
So that's, when you talk
about young people, that's
not some kind of flaw in a
young person's character.
It's just that they're living
in a world in which they've
been able to avoid
difficult conversations,
or outsource all of the
pain of these interactions.
And that has effects.
And one of the effects is that
they're not as empathetic.
They're less likely to be
empathetic than their parents
and grandparents.
Now, smartphone use at
this point is widespread.
In fact according to the UN,
more people at this point
have access to a cell
phone than working toilet.
So that's not just a
millennial problem.
That's just a modern human
being problem at this point.
SPEAKER 1: You talked
about the breakdown
of communication between groups
with different viewpoints.
What do you think
we can do to improve
those lines of communication?
CELESTE HEADLEE:
Well, we have to stop
thinking that there are some
people that you can't talk to.
That's not a thing.
And there is no such
thing as somebody
you have zero in
common with, also.
If you think that, you're wrong.
That The problem is, is
that we have to move out
of our ideological bubbles.
And I think that
phrase has been used
so much that it's kind of
been vacated of meaning,
but it's absolutely true.
Pew has done some of the best
research on this of anyone.
And we are all living
in ideological bubbles.
White people, especially, tend
to only have white friends.
And if they do
interact with somebody
who is a person of
color at work that's
not the person that they go
home and interact with at home.
Does that mean that
people of color
are going to have different
political opinions with you?
No, but they probably have
a different experience
than you do.
And the research on
diversity, in terms
of how much it helps us
grow, is just definitive.
But there's also this
incredible research on how much
it helps us actually
problem solve at work.
So it's really fascinating.
I get very geeked
out by these numbers.
But, OK, so when
you study people's
problem-solving problems.
Just the chance that you're
going to bring somebody
in the group that has,
possibly, a different opinion,
makes everybody work better.
The chance that there might
be pushback and argument
makes the quality of
everybody's work go up,
just that opportunity.
So when you're only surrounding
yourself with people
that you think are
going to agree with you,
you know, you're not growing.
You're not evolving.
SPEAKER 1: That kind
of ties into how
we're cognitive misers.
And we like to be in
comfortable situations.
So, how do we actively
tell ourselves like--
well, how you remind yourself
about these 10 conversations
tips.
Do you have any
cues that you use?
CELESTE HEADLEE:
Well, it's easy for me
because that's what
I do all day, right.
And not only that, but I
have reminders constantly
that I'm not the smart--
I have zero illusions
that I'm the smartest
person in the world.
Like, that's one of the best
things about a TED conference,
right.
Like, there is no
competition on my part
to be the smartest person
at a TED conference.
Like, the pressure is off.
But if I'm also, like if
I'm interviewing some CDC
person who's out risking her
life in Africa to fight Ebola,
my problems with my Galaxy phone
pretty much pale in comparison.
Like, it is very easy for
me to keep myself in context
and stay humble.
You know, if I'm talking
to Salman Rushdie,
I'm not the smartest person
in the studio at that point.
So it's very easy for me to do.
But I think that for all of
us, the most important thing
is just to force yourself
to start the conversation.
That's it.
Don't try to keep the rest
of it in your mind at all.
Just A, ask more questions, and
B, just have the conversation.
Force yourself to do it.
Your Uber driver's there.
My Uber driver had "I
Voted" stickers all over.
And I was like, looks like
you don't miss an election.
And he went into
this long description
of how he got to America,
and the day that he
got his citizenship,
and, you know,
how frustrated he
gets and ba ba ba.
I didn't have to say a word.
Like, again, pressure was off.
I didn't have to say anything.
I landed on something that
he was incredibly proud of,
and I just sat back and
listened to his stories.
And I would encourage everybody
just to do the same thing.
You know, people are
amazing, even the--
can I swear?
Even the shitty
ones are amazing.
They are.
I mean, I'm a mixed-race person.
I've had plenty of
conversations with Sons
of Confederate Veterans
and former KKK members.
I've had conversations
with people
who I would find
detestable in regular life.
That's my job, is I'm the one
that has to go and have those
respectful conversations
with those people.
And you know what,
I'm better for it.
I am so much better for it.
And they were good
conversations.
I learned stuff
from those people.
So I would just say, just
have the conversation.
You're not-- they don't
get money or any benefit
from you listening to them.
You're not helping
them by listening.
You're just having a human
interaction with them.
And you know there's this great,
this guy named Darrell Davis.
There's a PBS
documentary about him.
He's a jazz musician by night,
but his hobby during the day
is talking KKK members
into leaving the group.
And he's so successful,
he's a black guy by the way,
he's so successful at it that
he almost individually, alone,
disabled the KKK operation
in the state of Maryland
by himself.
And the way that
he does that is he
doesn't try to convince
them not to be racists.
He says, I just listen
to them, and sometimes
people just want to be heard.
And I think just being
heard, giving someone
the gift of being heard
is one of the simplest,
least expensive, best
things you can possibly do,
even if they're shitty.
SPEAKER 1: You talked
about the person
who had the stickers in
the back of their car.
Are those kind of like
conversation hooks?
CELESTE HEADLEE: Everything
is a conversation hook, right.
Like someone's going to wear
a particular hat, or I mean,
you can find something
that somebody
has that they care about.
You know, like your Fitbit.
I can ask you about your Fitbit.
You're going to explain.
And you did.
Actually, when Ashley
asked you about it,
you said well, I dee
dee dee duh dee dee duh,
and you started
talking about it.
You ask questions they know the
answer to about something they
care about.
It's really simple.
They're always,
there's always going
to be something
about that person.
And if it's not,
sometimes it's something
that really annoys them.
Like, I asked somebody
about their haircut
and she goes, oh my god, I
had to get it chopped off
because she ruined
my hair, ba ba ba
but she was still
talking, you know.
I could still just sit
back and listen to her
rather than put in a huge
amount of effort on my part.
SPEAKER 1: Right, and
gave her validation,
like she's being heard.
CELESTE HEADLEE: And
remember the Harvard study.
Don't forget the
2014 Harvard study.
Talking about yourself
gives you the same pleasure
as sex and cocaine.
OK, so if you're giving
someone the opportunity
to talk about
themselves, they're
going to feel great, right?
You have, with
very little effort,
made them feel fantastic.
It totally works with your boss.
SPEAKER 1: So regarding
that feeling of failure
about not talking to somebody.
How do you-- how can
people overcome that?
Are there simple tricks?
CELESTE HEADLEE:
The fear of failure?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
Yeah, like people
don't want to reach
out and say something
because they want to say the
best thing to this person
and they don't know how
to start a conversation.
How do you overcome
that fear of failure?
CELESTE HEADLEE: I don't
actually know that.
I would just say that the best
thing to do is just try it.
And if it doesn't
go well, walk away.
Say excuse me, and walk off.
I mean, I've done
it a million times.
I don't find an excuse.
One of the biggest
problems is that we try,
sometimes we try to explain why
we're leaving a conversation.
We're like I have to go
and well, clean out my car.
I dropped whatever, you
know, you just say, excuse me
for a moment, and you walk off.
It's very simple.
If it's not going
well, walk away
and try it with someone else.
You know, if you say
something stupid,
and I say stupid
things all the time,
just say, excuse me for a
moment, and you walk off.
And then you can moan about how
dumb that thing was in private
and start with somebody else.
SPEAKER 1: That's excellent.
Do we have any
audience questions?
We'll get you a mic in a second.
Thank you Allison.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I love the TED talk and
this was great, too.
I'm already breaking
be brief, because I
haven't asked my question
yet, but I'm going to ask you.
So much great stuff,
you mentioned the lack
of empathy being a
problem with, you know,
proliferation of cell phones,
technology, and all that.
I agree 100%.
I'm wondering if you have any
thoughts besides modeling,
maybe, of how we can get
especially the younger
generation to maybe put down
the phone once in a while
and have a conversation.
CELESTE HEADLEE: So
other than forcing them,
which I can only
do with my own kid,
I don't actually know
the answer to that.
And it's a really big question.
Like I know that in
my house, not even
adults are allowed to bring
their cell phones to the table.
That's just the rule.
And if you want to keep
cell phone, that's fine,
but you're not eating,
in my place anyway.
So, you just kind of
have to set limitations
for yourself, and not in a jerky
asshole way, but just like,
this is how I do it.
So, you know, that's
the way that goes.
You know, it's funny,
and people are trying
all kinds of different things.
Chick-Fil-A, the
chicken place, they now
have this thing in a
lot of the restaurants
where there is bucket in
the middle of the table,
and if you throw your
cell phones in there
and don't touch them, they'll
give you a free ice cream
at the end of your meal.
And the ice creams
are only $1.25,
but if you multiply that
by the number of people
that eat in Chick-Fil-A,
that's a pretty huge investment
in trying to encourage
people to talk.
I have no idea if it's
going to work or not.
But I think that
this is the moment
right now when we have
to start thinking about,
how do we do this?
So, you know, cell phone
addiction is, it's a thing.
Like it's a real problem.
It's as bad, if not worse, than
gambling or food addiction.
And, especially
if you're in tech,
and you're a
responsible tech person,
this is something that
should be on your mind.
How do we make it so that tech
does not ruin our humanity?
I mean that's kind of
where we are right now
and mine is not the best mind to
kind of think of that solution.
But maybe yours is.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a lot about how
crummy email and text are.
At Google, we are in multiple
countries, multiple offices,
work with people
all over the world.
Are there tips and
tricks for conversations
that are, perhaps not email,
but phone or video conference?
And are those better modes of--
CELESTE HEADLEE: Yes, video
conferences are totally legit.
Phone conversation
is totally legit.
And now, one of the things
that email does well,
remember I said that it
only does a few things well.
One of them is that time
lapse, handling time lapse.
It also, you know, it's one
of the best ways to, you know,
send an attachment.
It's also the best way to recap
a meeting or a phone call.
So for example, if
I have something
where I need a
nuance, or we need
to sort of hash something out,
I will always do that by phone.
And I make people
do it by phone.
Like, they'll try
to do it in email
and I'll say, I don't think
this is the kind of thing we're
going to be able to
handle over email,
give me a time when
you have five or 10
minutes on the phone, right.
And then I will call
him on the phone.
And then when the phone
conversation is done,
then I send an email
saying, here's what I heard.
This is what we talked about.
Is this what you heard also?
That's where you can use email
really, really productively.
But to have any
kind of discussion
over email, every
bit of research
that we have shows the
email makes it worse.
It's It's a productivity killer.
It's an innovation killer.
It's much better to
have it by phone.
Now, a video
conference, absolutely.
Your phone call, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Remember, you know,
there's three parts
to successful
communication, right.
There's the words that you use,
the vocabulary, what they mean.
Then there's your body language.
And then there's
your tone of voice.
So there's a reason why we
make jokes about sarcasm font,
right.
It's because me, if I
say (tentative) maybe
that's really different me going
(cheerful affirmative) maybe,
right.
One of them means no.
And that is not translated
through your printed word.
This is why we have
Damn You Auto Correct!
This is why we have all those
things making fun of how
bad texting communication is.
When you are just
emailing or texting,
you're removing
2/3 of the meaning
from what it is
that you're saying.
So it's not at all surprising
that miscommunications
happen all the time.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for coming.
Super geeking out
about everything
that you are geeking out about.
It's fantastic.
Are you familiar with, I'm
sorry I forget the speaker,
but it's another TED talk called
"The Power of Vulnerability."
CELESTE HEADLEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does that
sound familiar?
So I'm curious
about how that fits
into what you're talking
about, because it seems
to be a thing that opens
up good conversation,
but is more about talking
instead of listening.
CELESTE HEADLEE: Yes.
OK, so I think
that is a great TED
talk, and wonderful,
wonderful area of research.
It's a little different
than what I talk about.
Related, but a little different.
In my world, you
show vulnerability
by giving up control,
by allowing someone else
to share the platform with you.
In a conversation,
there's a thing
called conversational
narcissism, which
is what most of us
practice, including myself.
I do not except myself
from that at all.
But we're basically maintaining
control of a conversation,
and it allows us to keep
the focus on ourselves
and what we like to talk about.
Now if you're going to
truly be vulnerable,
that's when you hand over some
of that control to someone
else.
The vulnerability
is really essential.
But in this particular case,
it's not self-disclosure.
Self-disclosure, you're
already primed to do.
Self-disclosure is
just the scientific way
of saying talking
about yourself.
And, as I mentioned,
it feels great.
So I'm never really
all that worried
about people and
self-disclosure.
I'm worried about them allowing
other people to self-disclose.
SPEAKER 1: Well, thank you
so much for joining us.
We really enjoyed this talk,
and I look forward to hearing
more about what you're
doing with your research
and everything.
So thank you for joining us.
CELESTE HEADLEE: Thank
you, my pleasure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]